in your work you've worked with I mean
probably thousands of I mean really
really amazing high-performing men so so
what what do you find that that really
really separates those those men the you
know some of the men who are just like
literally the the best in the world at
at what they do
yeah well like I said I mean to me one
of the greatest traits in a man and like
you said I've been very very fortunate
to work with some really high profile
high-performing man it is a depth and a
clarity that allows them to cut through
whatever you know whatever other things
occur here and stay on course in a very
distinct way while we're being very
deeply relaxed and that is a quality
it's something that I've only seen in in
the man who really have achieved what
they wanted to achieve that depth of
relaxation combined with the strengths
of correct charity yeah yeah what do you
say - I feel like in today's world
there's there's almost there's so many
options right with the internet and it
seems like a lot of my friends even
those who are who are entrepreneurs
depending on the week they they're
practicing on their handstands or on
their marketing or on this and there's
there's almost so much so many things
that that we can be and and it's it's
interface right with the internet and
there's that kind of paradox of choice
that I almost feel like keeps men from
from committing to a path yeah yeah I
think that's definitely true to me um
you know when you were saying what are
the traits of high-performing man the
other thing that all the men that I work
with were really high performing both
personally and financially you know in
the success realm they don't self
reference a lot and so on the country
they're mostly don't self reference at
all or very little you know other than
when it's really needed and so
regardless of what they do you
it's never about them getting something
or going somewhere it's just whatever
needs to be done is done and some of it
is just for the enjoyment of it and some
of it is because it's along the path so
I'm not necessarily opposed to a man
doing yoga one week and you know
marketing the next if it's not in
response to thinking that he's not good
enough and if he can just learn this one
then it's gonna be okay oh [ __ ] this
didn't work well let me try this one
then it's gonna be okay so it's the the
lack of feeling that there's something
deficient or wrong that makes it that
anything that that's been touched and or
being tried is kind of more a natural
expression of the abundance that is life
versus the grasping for the next thing
that could potentially save his life so
to speak yeah can you can you speak more
to what that means on how a man doesn't
he doesn't self self-reference well
there's there's many aspects of self
referencing the way I use it is both in
physical thought and emotional so in
physical into a physical expression you
often see people self reference when
they touch themselves you know and see
that of course you know if you've ever
been to an insane asylum which I have
you know it's like this thing that way
I'm here I mean I mean okay I'm still
here I'm good I'm good a good people do
that to lesser degrees but when you
watch it like for instance an airport
there's a lot of that girl and a lot of
fidgeting a lot of unconscious smacking
of the gum you know ticks adjusting this
kind of so those are self referencing
these behaviors that are physical where
there's a constant attention on am I
still here am I still the human that I
am am I still separate is everything
still okay that's a that's a you know
physical self referencing the mental
self referencing goes from everything
like you know am I good enough am I good
enough in my winning am I losing is it
okay is this okay that she like me that
the constant internal talk that also
comes out in the way somebody speaks
where it's often all about them and
their needs
how it applies to you know yoga one-week
marketing another is that a lot of men
have to feel like they're doing
something valuable so that their
existence is not you know put in
question so it's a constant I'm doing
this I'm doing your I'm doing it I'm
doing good I'm doing good it's like it's
it's this but in a you know in a verbal
and you know mental and emotional way
where it's all about affirming that
everything's still okay and that things
are being done so that things get better
versus doing things for the sheer
pleasure or joy of doing them or because
they need to be done and not so
concerned with the constant reaffirming
of the self through action that improves
the self yeah some more more of that
that being versus doing this what if
being versus doing what a relaxation
versus push more than feeling outwards
versus feeling what's happening inside
and so the the high high performing man
I work with spend very little time on
their inner emotional landscape
interestingly enough they'll talk with
me about it if I make them oh but it's
an afterthought this also applies of
course you know that there's a fine
difference I'm saying you know that
because you live in California you know
there's a fine difference between having
healthy raw or whatever kind of foods
you know pal paleo or whatever people
are into foods for the sake of
optimizing performance and well-being
and for the sake of self referencing
because one is better than or if one
eats the right kind of food one is
considered more advanced or you know
separate from other people who are not
eating that well and we're exercising
as a part of is putting yourself apart
from other people so there's there's
always that searching for the new thing
to be separate better than standing out
being okay and then there's doing the
exact same things might look exactly the
same way for the sake of optimizing